[Music]
i feel like queen bee is like you know
it's not summer until i drop so we
respect it
break my soul's lyric video racked up
almost 3 million views in just 18 hours
i'm building my own foundation
the dance single samples robin s show me
love
which is such a classic house anthem
also collaborating new orleans queen of
bounce legend big frida she also
contributed to formation what's your
reaction when you heard it still trying
to pinch myself to wake up my manager
you know called and said that beyonce
want to use one of your songs
on her new album i'm like holy crap did
you go into the studio this time with
her this time they called me to
come to the studio in l.a to listen to
the track right before i got ready to
leave they're like beyonce is here do
you want to see her and talk to her you
know i needed an asthma pump once i left
out of the building
the beehive oh it's buzzing cynthia rivo
danced on her balcony actor titus
burgess in tears up all night listening
on repeat i had to be at work in 20
minutes
she put two years of love into this
billboard's hair on mamo says the track
signals a new era for beyonce there's
going to be a lot of dance and country
music beyonce she's been working
all right from beyonce summer jam to
kate bush's big comeback
after it was featured on stranger things
kate's 1985 classic running up that hill
has become a worldwide phenomenon
blowing up on tick-tock
[Music]
and jumping to number four on the
billboard charts in the u.s
the song gets an edgy remix in the new
trailer for the series that just dropped
today on the show the song is max's
anchor to reality she's in a lot of pain
and she's grieving
and
you know she's having all these really
dark thoughts and then she gets her life
saved by kate bush
by kate bush yes kate says she's really
moved by it all we sat down with her
back in 1985 and even back then she felt
a special connection to kids i think
music is a very strong force on all
children when you're teenaged you have
songs that go with every relationship
it's an important thing
[Music]
you